thank you to audible for sponsoring this
video audible has an unmatched amount of
audiobooks that you can play on any
device you can play on your iPhone on
Android iPad you name it you could play
it on there
I am currently listening to good to
great by Jim Collins and I absolutely
love the book so far just because it
explains how great companies become
great and how a bad company can also
become pretty great
there is also speed control so you can
listen to the audio supervisor or a lot
slower there are free exchanges and you
can keep the book even if you cancel the
membership audible is great to listen on
road trips or any fun summer activity to
get a free audiobook and a 30-day free
trial go to audible.com slash just
kidding news or this for its really cool
you can text just kidding news - 500 -
500 so again that's audible.com slash
just kidding news or you can text just
kidding news - 500 - 500 thank you
now enjoy the episode in creamy
discovery now submitted by Sabrina the
Teenage Witch
oh hi Brina that's what the why that's
why from the get off what is it the
psalm marina Sabrina the Teenage Gypsy I
guess so I love those gypsy shows like
my Gypsy Wedding my [ __ ] gypsy sister
my gypsy uncle like oh there's that dude
it's [ __ ] dough there's a gypsy
culture they're like all over they're
like in America Europe whatever but
they're I guess they're like from
Romania or they don't know where they're
from well I don't know where they're
really from but they traveled all over
they remind me of Hmong people right
well yes there's a Hmong people from
different Asian countries so they give
gypsies are from all over Eastern
Eastern Europe they're like why people
that are belly dancers what exactly is a
gypsy
wait isn't a gypsy somebody tries to rip
you off yeah but that's that's the bad
idea of gypsy that's like that's like -
gypsies are scammers right that's what
we know that's not bad that's the bad
stereotype that they have
now anyway the thing is they dress like
hoes but they're very traditional dress
they're there they know that they dress
revealing that's like a part of the
culture like big just dressed like
hoochie mamas but yeah like little ass
[ __ ] thing and then like [ __ ] big
I like [ __ ] sequins beads and your
culture geo is that there's [ __ ] karma
to say dress revealing but they're
actually very honest and they don't
[ __ ] have sex until they're married
that's not fair it's the worst culture
on earth by far in terms of like if
that's true like you have to your
abstinence while these women are just
more scantily clad every day okay right
now gypsies right if that's like me
watching Jersey Shore's ironing and
saying that's Italian culture like I
don't know you know this is just all
these shows that they pop they probably
[ __ ] it up for all the the travel or
people gypsies are the most
strong-willed men on earth then you just
have to be abstinent you stare at women
have it all day and yeah cuz they dress
hot yeah they're really hot so the poor
dudes are like yeah yeah that's tough no
they're horny
I could tell anyway let's get into it
man finds human bones buried his garden
and is stunned by his wife's response oh
this is sweet
what does his wife say like oh those
that was that remember our annoying
neighbor she actually said don't worry
it's my first husband cuz she killed
them [ __ ] or she doing jokes
dark joke I think she's honest woman
just too old to tell jokes she confessed
to killing her 52 year old husband 21
years ago oh my god her first husband
with an axe during the fights and
dismembered him and buried him in her
potato patch and now they have one of
the most delicious potatoes this is why
people always like statistically men
kill way more than women I'm like women
get away with it bud yeah I dare crafty
dudes that's a good clean kill and she
covered it up yeah
mrs. Li you lost me there I don't know
where he was said when you said this
very clearly this is his leak very
clearly clearly not for you to repeat it
tried it with the pants down together
that takes place in a village in Russia
oh [ __ ] of Serbia that's where I think
I'm not racist but I was like it's not
in America I'm not racist but is the
greatest preface to any sentence yeah
because women probably do get away with
it more because I've pretty much read
almost every article on earth just like
you know where a guy bury somebody and
they always get caught always like
apparently they just have blood on their
face as they walk out the door
we're not crafty I feel that we're not
well thought-out we don't put the grass
patch back over the dirt it's just front
lawn with the big square of dirt still
look she probably planned it like we're
crimes of passion kind of guys right
yeah like we're like we found you doing
a thing and now we're gonna do this
punish you and women are like oh really
[ __ ] I'm gonna do it ain't your
plan to kill you and there you get my
flower bed but what I don't understand
is if I did something guilty right like
and Nikki is in the area of where my
guilty thing is I'm like stay away from
over there yeah I mean like when when
when we were about to get married and I
was about to propose and I had her I put
her ring in like a [ __ ] bucket on top
of the fridge cuz she doesn't ever see
anything that's up like every any time
the shoes next the fridge I was like you
don't I mean but this cat she full-on
let your husband do yard work yeah
doesn't go like hey no it's Jill you
don't mean he's like hey honey I'm gonna
go dig holes the backyard she's like
that's fine I just picked her Nikki
going to the fridge you're like what the
[ __ ] yeah I was just I was just sweat
every time I'm like six months that is a
very long time you really doesn't look
up there but the trick to is that I use
I get sometimes I get ingrown toenails
in my in my toenails right I get England
Tourism attorneys and I use that bucket
to soak my toe so she wants to go
nowhere near
that's smart and you put that Buccaneer
since that's what I wanted to say what I
was like I put it in what liquor cereal
in the food area you don't put your
cereal that's on top of the page you
know I don't put my Siri on top of the
fridge not a gangster
I put buckets on top of the fridge okay
oh yeah we don't have space either so we
always put it up in the pot and the
[ __ ] of it everyone knows that I
can't even reach above the fridge
we have cupboards on top of our fridge
now that's the new school shift yeah we
have a pantry dude we made it bad see
that's the real I need a pantry that's
not your walk-in pantry by the way it
looks like a bomb shelter like you're
waiting for some disaster I like you
guys don't even cook in here it's all
processed foods problem got hella food
that I can't
that's apocalypse food yep
it just makes me feel good just to open
it I like looking for display purposes
you got [ __ ] Kansas sardines and
[ __ ] spam and you're like that
expired like yeah I actually lost weight
doing that years ago really like ten
years ago I filled my freezer with all
my favorite ice cream and I and anytime
I want an ice cream I would go up to it
and I would [ __ ] smell it and I'd be
like not today that's deadly with that
satisfied my like it's a cuz I have it I
physically have it but I don't have to
eat it and I can smell it and kind of
taste it through smelling it same but I
don't have it that I'm like oh I really
want it but when it's there I'm like
it's gonna get demolished oh yeah I
relate to that I buy a lot of snacks and
forget that it exists they by the way
they can open up their own [ __ ]
Baskin Robbins at their house
she was like you want ice cream oh oh do
you have ice cream she goes do I have
ice cream [ __ ] like 13 different
flavors
oh [ __ ] it was wild you got like the CVS
ice cream setup dude yeah she don't [ __ ]
around
we don't [ __ ] around they don't [ __ ]
around there right ate it right oh they
don't [ __ ] around at the right is
cheapest [ __ ] it is yeah I gotta buy
that cylinder [ __ ] cone that's the
jam yeah it makes it taste better it
does make it like that I scream is like
some weird [ __ ] but it's still delicious
that pecan butter one I'm like my
favorite one that's one of them they had
like this one with my pretzels and like
dude that [ __ ] was [ __ ] good man boys
there's like pretzels chocolate butter
yeah I was like sorry pretzel like
chocolate-covered so [ __ ] good so
this lady finds her husband buried she
was arrested
why would he yeah she did tell them like
oh just burying the remains again forget
about it we want to look police the
thing he went to the police what up
[ __ ] holy hell why would he do that
he was already not happy foods marriage
yeah that's rosty looking for now she's
a writer died you were just dude but not
knocking on your wife is not an excuse
man I'd rather just and yeah narc call
my wife she killed her first husband he
could die too
oh that's an excellent point I didn't
that's what you're saying but then at
the same I've been with this person
forever so I'm just like the
relationship is good it was probably bad
that's what I say like it's probably bad
well we could've been beating her the
whole time that's what she claims she
claims that she did it in self-defense
cuz apparently one day the man came home
drunk and started feeding her well then
for him to rat her out
it was probably bad been to this pi bond
relationship yeah because I would have
[ __ ] turn I would actually like love
my wife more me too man I blame you did
some gangster [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah your [ __ ] ratings just went
up I'm like I thought I knew you
I thought I knew you but now there's
another side you're telling me if you
found out KC killed a previous wife or
girlfriend no I ate he was a [ __ ]
badass no wait why is why his ex-wife
used to beat him silly and one day he
was like I'm not taking this [ __ ]
pain anymore
and then he [ __ ] kills or buries her
in a tomato patch what are you gonna do
yeah everything you guys have been
through up until this point he's been
there for all the ups and downs yes or
no tip yeah what do you do I'm Finnish
answer the question tip [ __ ] nah leave
[ __ ] you're busy you just went to
Morocco yeah I would I would love for
more David we're ganging up on TIFF
right now oh yeah what the [ __ ] you
can't thank you
you leave Mary oh of course you would I
can't be with no [ __ ] murderer no no
I'm out I could be with the murder any
day you're that's crazy cuz you know how
many times she's looked at me and said
I'll [ __ ] kill you now it's real
that's real every time she says are you
like oh [ __ ] yeah now I'm like you have
a flashing your head of literally a
skeleton of a man who died for that
exactly like though that's what I
actually like so if geo told me I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you tell him that
every [ __ ] day right I like you
[ __ ] lying sack of [ __ ] but if I
found out she killed someone I'm like
thank god they're finally telling the
truth to me it's a layered thing what's
a layered thing this whole thing's like
a layer cake so the first thing is you
ever get in trouble you're not defending
yourself in court first of all no it's
two layers so the fact that she just
killed someone already I'm just not just
20 years it's been a while 20 years ago
the fact that she she killed someone
that's one thing the other thing is the
fact that she dismembered his body and
buried him it has to be compacted you
have no loyalty got to do this it looks
like you have no loyalty
that's how I would do it if it was a JK
party rhythm game that's funny how even
calling the cops is an option because I
would immediately go I got a killer
first what if we rap having problems
exactly a constant laughs people I call
I'm like oh my god
that means I have to kill her before she
kills me that's what enters my mind
before calling the cops
is that loyalty to you at least he has
loyalty Keenan are
hey no rat I am loyal I wasn't saying
I'm gonna narc on him like I'm just
leaving I don't want to be the next big
go why she didn't do anything she didn't
do anything wrong
he's cleaning up his own messes and
you're waiting for other people clean up
here man right okay I found a way I
found a way but if the relationships
good I'm like oh you kept somebody oh
well maybe I gotta go kill somebody so
we could be equals you're thinking of it
like it's not sweet hairless Casey that
we all know and love he's very sweet
under him right so let's see imagine
that actually sweet heroes case sweet
dimpled hail escape
you're really gonna narc on him and send
him to prison I never said I would knock
on him you might as well cuz you're
gonna break his heart or run away he did
nothing wrong
you're putting his [ __ ] heart in
prison he was defending himself she all
still has a think about her child too
but he took care of your child yeah he
wakes up in the morning it drives him to
SCU's we're gonna send someone as smooth
as tell you call your a deadbeat mother
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you guys now
why'd you say he took care of her child
so she should return the favor and just
stay and stay with him he didn't do
anything to you and if any you girls are
watching this and you're this disloyal -
shame on you shame on their kidding
I would totally narc on fire Tricia now
you want in you're so [ __ ] loyal is
disgusting that's true
[Music]